THE SHOOTING OF RAYSHARD BROOKS.
SHE DID NOTHING WRONG, SHE WAS
MERELY RELATED TO THE WRONG
PERSON.
THE FIRST GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON.
WE INTERVIEWED A U.S. SENATOR
CALLED MIKE BRAUN.
HE RAN FOR OFFICE TWO YEARS AGO
AS A CONSERVATIVE BUT HE HAS NOT
GOVERNED A LIKE ONE.
MIKE BRAUN USED HIS POWER IN THE
U.S. SENATE TO PUNISH LOCAL
POLICE.
COPS WERE THE REAL PROBLEM HE
DECIDED SO HE SPONSORED
LEGISLATION TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR LEFT-WING ACTIVIST GROUPS TO
SUE AND BANKRUPT INDIVIDUAL
POLICE OFFICERS AND THEN MIKE
BRAUN ENDORSED BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
>> TO SUPPORT THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER MOVEMENT?
>> I SUPPORT THAT MOVEMENT
BECAUSE IT’S LIKE ADDRESSING AN
EQUITY WHICH HAS NOT BEEN SOLVED
FROM THE GRASSROOTS LEVEL.
>> Tucker: IT’S HARD TO
IMAGINE THAT ANY OF MY BRONZE,
AND INSTALLED SOCIALISM IN THE
UNITED STATES.
EVEN IN THE HIGHLY REVOLUTIONARY
YEAR OF 2020 OF THOSE DO NOT
SEEM LIKE WINNING INSTITUTIONS
IN THE STATE OF INDIANA.
WE WILL SUMMIT LIKE THIS WAY.
HE WAS PUSHING LEFT-WING
LEGISLATION BECAUSE HE WAS
AFRAID OF BEING CRITICIZED BY
CHUCK SCHUMER IF HE DIDN’T.
THE WHOLE THING WENT LIKE THAT
AND IT WAS REMARKABLE, ALMOST
BEYOND BELIEF.
AGAIN, WE ARE NOT TRYING TO BE
MEAN HERE.
CRUELTY IS TOO EASY ESPECIALLY
WITH POLITICIANS AND THE CLOSER
YOU GET TO THEM THE EASIER YOU
REALIZE IT IS.
MIKE BRAUN DOESN’T SEEM LIKE A
BAD PERSON, IF YOU LIVE NEXT
DOOR TO HIM YOU PROBABLY LIKE
HIM.
BUT HE IS WEAK.
AN AWFUL LOT OF REPUBLICAN
OFFICEHOLDERS LOOK A LOT LIKE MY
CLOSE WRONG.
THAT’S A PROBLEM.
IN A MOMENT LIKE THIS IT’S A
SEVERE AND DANGEROUS PROBLEM.
IF THEY LOSE THIS, IT WILL BE
PROFOUND CONSEQUENCES FOR YOU.
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORTED
DONALD TRUMP WILL BE PUNISHED,
ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
THERE’S NEVER BEEN A POLITICAL
PARTY AS RADICAL AND AS ANGRY AS
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOW.
IMAGINE THEM WITH UNLIMITED
POWER AND NOT TO GET IN THE
FIRST YEAR OF DEMOCRATS WILL
GIVE VOTING RIGHTS TO EVERY
ILLEGAL ALIEN IN THIS COUNTRY
AND ENCOURAGE MANY OTHERS TO
JOIN THEM FROM ABROAD.
THAT MEANS 20 MILLION NEW
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS OVERNIGHT.
NO REPUBLICAN WILL WIN
NATIONALLY AGAIN.
BUT DEMOCRATS DON’T PLAN TO STOP
THERE.
THEY WILL ABOLISH THE FILIBUSTER
WHICH MEANS THEY WILL DO WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO.
THEY ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT THAT,
THEY PLAN TO PACK THE
SUPREME COURT, TOO.
THEY SAID SO.
SO WHAT WILL DEMOCRATS DO WITH
ALL OF THIS UNTRAMMELED POWER?
IT’S PRETTY EASY TO IMAGINE.
BUT LOOK AT AROUND.
YOU GOT A PRETTY GOOD IDEA OF
WHAT’S COMING.
THE POINT IS, AND IT COULD NOT
BE MORE CLEAR, NONDEMOCRATS IN
AMERICA ARE IN PERIL.
THAT’S WHERE, AND TO REMIND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT IT IS OUR
ONLY SHIELD.
FLAWED AND INFURIATING ALTHOUGH
IT OFTEN IS, THE FACT REMAINS
THAT G.O.P. IS THE ONLY
INSTITUTION STILL OPEN TO THE
REST OF US.
TWO AMERICANS WHO WANT TO LIVE
AS THEY DID JUST 15 YEARS AGO,
QUIETLY AND PRODUCTIVELY BY IT
SELF LUNATICS WHO WANT TO BE
HARMED AND THEY DO.
YOU WANT TO BE LEFT ALONE TO DO
YOUR JOB AND RAISE YOUR FAMILY
IN THIS COUNTRY YOU WILL NEED A
PROTECTOR.
THAT PROTECTOR MUST BE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, THERE ARE NO
OTHER OPTIONS, BUT IT MUST BE A
VERY DIFFERENT KIND OF
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
KEEP IN MIND YOU ARE GETTING OUR
REPUBLICAN PARTY MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS.
ONCE DONALD TRUMP IS GONE,
FORMER GOVERNOR NIKKI HALEY TOPS
THAT LIST.
BUT THERE ARE MANY OTHERS ON IT.
THEY TELL YOU REPUBLICANS LOST
POWER, AND IF YOU LISTEN
CAREFULLY YOU CAN HEAR THEM SAY
THAT EVEN NOW.
IT’S ALIVE.
REPUBLICANS ARE FAILING FOR A
FUNDAMENTAL REASON AND THEY ARE
FAILING BECAUSE THEY HAVEN’T
DONE MUCH THAT IS WORTH DOING.
THEY HAVEN’T TRIED VERY HARD TO
IMPROVE YOUR LIFE AND WHEN THE
CRISIS CAME THEY FLED.
THEY DID NOTHING TO DEFEND YOU
AND DID NOTHING TO DEFEND THE
COUNTRY.
THEY HAD NO CLUE WHAT TO DO.
FROM THIS DAY FORWARD, AND THAT
WILL WORK.
THAT’S ORGANIZE GROUPS OF VOTERS
AND THEY WANT TO WIN.
SO THEY HAD TO WEAR THE VOTES
ARE.
THEY DEMANDED THREE THINGS FROM
THEIR CANDIDATES.
FIRST, IT’S A VIGOROUS DEFENSE
OF TOTAL EQUALITY UNDER THE LAW.
WE ARE EQUAL BECAUSE WE ARE
CITIZENS.
EVERY AMERICAN HAS PRECISELY THE
SAME RIGHTS AS EVERY OTHER
AMERICAN, PERIOD.
THAT IS THE PROMISE OF AMERICA
AND WHY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE MOVE
HERE.
FOR A LONG TIME WE KNEW THAT NO
ONE QUESTIONED IT, IT WAS
OBVIOUS.
BUT IT IS NO LONGER OBVIOUS AND
MANY WERE WORKING ON THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
REPUBLICANS MUST COUNTERBALANCE
THIS AND THEY MUST WORK AS HARD
AS THEY CAN TO MAKE AMERICA FAIR
AGAIN.
WELL, THAT MEANS THAT CRIMINALS
LIKE JEFFREY EPSTEIN MUST GO TO
JAIL THE FIRST TIME THEY ARE
CAUGHT MOLESTING CHILDREN.
IT MEANS YOUR CHILDREN MUST HAVE
PRECISELY THE SAME CHANCES OF
GETTING INTO COLLEGE OR GETTING
A JOB AS ANYONE ELSE’S CHILDREN.
IT MEANS FIGHTING TO MAKE THIS A
COLOR-BLIND MERITOCRACY A
COLOR-BLIND MERITOCRACY.
THEY WERE IMMORAL AND
REPUBLICANS MUST SAY THAT
LOUDLY.
DON’T GET CAUGHT IN POINTLESS
DEBATES ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS A RACIST COUNTRY,
CLEARLY IT ISN’T.
PROVE IT BY MAKING IT LESS
RACIST AND MAKING IT A
COLOR-BLIND MERITOCRACY.
SECOND, REPUBLICANS MUST DEFEND
OUR FREEDOM OF SPEECH, WE ARE
NOT A FREE SOCIETY WITHOUT THAT.
THIS IS NOT SIMPLY A DEBATE
ABOUT THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND
ITS LIMITS, IT’S BIGGER THAN
THAT AND MORE IMPORTANT.
IF YOU CAN’T ARTICULATE
SOMETHING, IF YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED, YOU CAN’T THINK IT AND
THAT’S PRECISELY WHY
AUTHORITARIANS TRY TO CONTROL
LANGUAGE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CONTROL YOUR
MIND.
REPUBLICANS SHOULD LEAD THE
FIGHT AGAINST THIS WITHOUT
SHAME.
THIS IS NOT NEGOTIABLE.
NOR IS IT A INTELLECTUAL
CONCERN.
EVERYTHING DEPENDS ON IT AND IF
YOU CAN’T THINK FREELY, TRY TO
BUILD A HYDRO PLANT.
THE POWER GRID COLLAPSES AND
PLANES CRASH, SOCIETY DEGRADES.
NO SPEECH MEANS NO SCIENCE, NO
ART AND NO CIVILIZATION AND IT
IS NOT SETTLED.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WILL NOT
FIGHT THEM.
AND FINALLY WE MUST NEVER FORGET
THAT IN THE END REPUBLICAN PARTY
EXISTS TO SERVE THE INTEREST OF
NORMAL PEOPLE, ORDINARY PEOPLE.
MIDDLE-CLASS FAMILIES OF THE
CORE OF THIS COUNTRY AND HOPE
FOR THE FUTURE, OUR ONLY HOPE.
AND YET BOTH PARTIES HAVE
SHAMELESSLY ABANDONED THEM.
THEY HAVE NO NATIONAL SPOKESMAN
THEY HAVE NO LOBBY IN
WASHINGTON.
REPUBLICANS PRETEND TO BE THEIR
CHAMPION BUT YOU KNOW BY NOW
THEY ARE NOT.
INSTEAD OF IMPROVING THE LIVES
OF THEIR VOTER IS THE PARTY
FEEDS THEM A STEADY DIET OF MY
MUST SEND THE VICTORIES,
PARTISAN JUNK FOOD DESIGNED TO
MAKE THEM FEEL FULL EVEN IF THEY
WASTE AWAY.
WHO CARES HOW MANY BENGHAZI
HEARINGS WE HAVE.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO CARE BUT WHY
SHOULD WE?
HOW DID PETER STRZOK’S TEXT
MESSAGES BECOME MORE IMPORTANT
THAN SAVING AMERICAN JOBS FROM
FOREIGN NATIONALS WHO ARE TAKING
THEM?
WE FALL FOR IT EVERY TIME.
WE APOLOGIZE WITH DEEPEST
SINCERITY.
BECAUSE MEANWHILE AS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THINGS THAT DON’T
MATTER, LIFE FOR THAT DWINDLING
AMERICAN MIDDLE CLASS HAS BECOME
SUDDENLY WORSE.
HER NEPHEW JUST DIED OF THE
FENTANYL OVERDOSE AND THE
SADDEST OF ALL, HE REALIZED THAT
YOUR CHILDREN WILL NEVER BE
SUCCESSFUL AS YOU ARE.
THE AMERICAN DREAM DIED WITH
REGENERATION.
AS ALL OF THIS HAPPENED,
DEMOCRATS LAUGHED BECAUSE IT
SERVED THEIR INTERESTS.
REPUBLICANS BASICALLY IGNORED IT
AND THAT CANNOT CONTINUE.
THE ONLY POLITICAL MOVEMENT THAT
INDOORS IS ONE THAT MAKES THEIR
VOTERS STRONGER.
SO HOW DOES THIS CHANGE?
CAN REPUBLICAN OFFICE HOLDERS
CHANGE THEIR PARTY?
YES THEY CAN, WE JUST HAVE TO
MAKE THEM.
THESE ARE NOT BY AND LARGE EVIL
PEOPLE, MIKE BRAUN IS NOT AN
EVIL PERSON.
DESPITE THE WAY THEY TALK THEY
ARE NOT SECRETLY WORKING FOR THE
OTHER SIDE.
MOST OF THEM ARE JUST EMPTY SAD
PEOPLE AND POLITICS IS THE WAY
THAT THEY FILLED A YAWNING VOID
INSIDE WHERE THEIR PERSONAL LIFE
SHOULD BE.
THEY ARE APPEASERS.
OUR JOB IS TO GIVE THEM CLEAR
INSTRUCTIONS ABOUT WHAT WE WANT.
WE DO THAT BY VOTING AND BY
MAKING NOISE.
THEY WILL NOT LEAD US AND WE